Lord Commander
Lord Commander! Wake up!
Giannis? What are you doing here?
I have to tell you something
What is it? Did Bango fall off the ladder?
No. They’re going to exile you. At dawn
[Sighs]
I knew this day would come
Demand a trial…a trial by one-on-one!
I will be your champion!
Giannis, you’re a good kid
No, you’re a good Kidd!
It’s not right. They blame you for everything!
Eh. Well
The analytics maesters blame you for all the corner
threes we give up!
I mean, it is my defensive scheme, so
And the fanlings say it’s your fault we don’t know
when to foul in the last two minutes of battle!
Yeah, well okay, I mean, that one sort of
Even though half the knights have given up on you!
Eleven of them, actually
Here
What is it? Breakfast smoothie?
Something like that
[Coughs]
I think your strawberries went bad
Listen, Giannis
I could adjust my schemes
I could stop blaming our youth
I could even work on my time management
But I won't
Because at the end of the day
I must be true to who I am
In here
And in here
I am an asshole
I’m a stubborn asshole and I don’t have a clue what I’m doing
But...but you’re the best Lord Commander I’ve ever had
I’m the only Lord Commander you’ve ever had
Wait, did you have Larry Drew for a year? Were you...
Did you have Larry Drew for a year?
Yeah, yes, who cares?
What matters is that it’s not fair what they do to you!
[Glass breaks]
You’re giving up on us! You’re giving up on me!
Don’t cry over spilled mead, Giannis!
When life gives you spilled mead...ugh
Use it to get a free timeout…
-Ah, the Big Dog
Glenn Robinson. One of House Bucks’ finest knights
I fought beside him under House Hawks. Years ago
Lord Commander never talked about him
But sometimes I’d find him down here lighting candles and praying to the statue
Those weren’t prayers
They were curses
Ser Glenn Robinson was the first pick of his draft class
Do you know who was second?
Lord Commander?
Aye. Well, Ex-Lord Commander
He would come down here to pay his disrespects
That resentment, that anger, that was Ser Kidd’s greatest weapon
and his greatest weakness
[Sighs]
We were just getting comfortable in his scheme
Ser Ray Allen
He was pretty comfortable fighting under George Karl
They spent years on the brink of conquering the East together
But they never did
Things grew toxic
Five years later, Ray was finally a champion
under Maester Rivers
his sixth Lord Commander
His Airness, Ser Jordan was a great knight under Doug Collins
but it was under the Zen Maester that he became a champion
-Don’t forget about Steph Curry, mate!
Ah!
What the? Delly?
He was quite comfortable with Mark Jackson
but Steve Kerr really put him over the top
What are you even doing down here?
I was just down here scrapping around
Actually found a pretty cool cave. You guys wanna come check this out?
Wow. What is this place?
This must be pre-merger
Ancient House Hawks maybe?
I don't know
Is that–is that Wilt Chamberlain?
Nay. George Mikan. The first giant
What–what is this? Look at all these pale dwarves
Oh my gods, these must be the White Men of the Forest
I only heard about them in stories
They were first to play this game
Looks normal to me
Look here. No three-point line
Why is he holding the ball like that?
They were too weak to shoot overhand
Some of these guys weren’t even full-time knights
They were tooth maesters when they weren’t playing
Man, this thing must be thousands of years old
Oh look over here
This guy's holding a basket
This looks like the earliest drawing
Oh yeah, that must be Maester Naismith
Wow
Legend has it, he settled Balleros and made our holy sport
He’s the father of us all
There, yeah! Look! It says here
Thou Maker. That’s him!
Wait...wait. That’s not a...
That says Thon! Thon Maker!
Uh, Jason?
How old did you say this was again?